efforts to modernize state aid policy
top the agenda when ministers
responsible for improving the European
Union's competitiveness meet in Brussels
in public deliberations the ministers
are expected to reach a political
agreement on the upgrade as the EU seeks
to focus on the most efficient and
ferris state aid airports and airlines
have routinely been involved in state
aid cases amid concerns about unfair
competition the idea is to ensure that
state funding helps address real market
failures promotes a competitive single
market and provides the best outcome for
the lowest price particularly in times
of recession if all goes according to
plan the reform could be completed by
the end of the year the European
Parliament must endorse the package for
it to enter into force also in open
forum the ministers will discuss
copyright rules in the EU and the
protection of authors and artists to
help foster creativity the plan is to
brainstorm ways to set up a more modern
framework for considering copyright laws
in the digital age and share views on
the e use fragmented markets in this
area the issue of private copying and
imposing levies in the EU has been tough
to resolve copyright levies vary widely
from country to country they can become
a lucrative source of income for rights
holders but can also create obstacles to
the free movement of goods and services
Europe's future research programme
horizon 2020 is also on the agenda The
ministers will assess progress made in
negotiations with the European
Parliament using their inputs the Irish
presidency hopes to reach an early
agreement on the seven-year programme
research ministers will also debate
joint programming which sets out ways to
best tackle the many challenges facing
society by better use of resources 10
such programs have been launched since
2009 on challenges like brain disorders
climate change and Urban Development